Sherwood up towards Center and McDavid
will hand off to Cece poke free by Kane
and now McDavid what a spin the recovery
the shot to score Conor McDavid it's not
real oh I'll tell you we've watched him for so
many years the way he works in the offseason on
edge control spinas everything he can do and in
situations like this you can never really to be
prepared for this but maybe he is the most he goes
down spin aama pops back up and somehow that puck
was loose I mean that's it is absolute nightmare
for that puck to be ahead of him when he gets up
but he attacks with so much speed doesn't even
miss a beat and then buries it on the breakway Wow
Let's Take a look at this again again the speeds
in the neutral zone attack he trips he stumbles
back right back up again head up and buries it no
chance for Soros you think he's done you think the
play over all of a sudden you got to get refocused
to try and stop the fastest guy in the league